[Music]
well uh welcome back to careful boys
and girls and girl
we are joined by girls it's very rare
it's it's still like hey careful boys
there's a girl here
does it feel weird to be in a room of so
many dudes
no
really you're very comfortable around us
yeah we went hiking
right now the first thing i [ __ ]
showed up she showed up yeah
we're like we're going on a hike
okay okay she's like cool i'm dressed
for the club thanks [ __ ]
thanks for the email can i bring my june
fox
yeah i did it was fun what you been up
to um cooking a lot um a lot of pop-ups
actually feeding people in real life so
that's been really cool
um
do you have a signature sauce you have a
signature sauce no i i think i saw you
do like fish sauce on ice cream or
something oh that's not fly by jing
chili crisp on ice cream no it was
actually chili crisp on ice cream and
then i made a fish sauce peanut brittle
that's right what if i projectile
vomited all over the place right now
that would be crazy what's fly by gene
fly by jing is i don't know [ __ ] about
the culinary world it's a sichuan chili
oil company yeah they have they have
chili crisp they have this sauce called
zhong but um jing the person that
created fly by jing she just she wants
to basically
um
change the story on chinese food um you
know how like what's the current story
only jewish people go there during
christmas i know you know how like when
you hear about chinese food you think of
like you think of like just um cheap
in the whole uh in the wall place hole
in the wall places um just stuff like
that panda express
that's true yeah
beef and broccoli stuff like that
by the way from beijing yeah
so she just wants to change the story on
that and she's been doing an amazing job
and it was actually a collaboration with
me and her at family style fest oh cool
so it was really fun and exciting what's
the story trying to change it into
they're trying to be surf ninjas
is the surf ninjas how do they get the
cream cheese in the rain goons
piping bag piping
do you know her the story that she wants
to change for chinese food well it's
more of like she wants to she wants to
put more respect on chinese food oh so
it's not like a cheap thing no how does
she feel about din tai phong i have no i
i've never asked maybe she should ask
sushi people here how do you feel about
have you been i loved in thailand
chinese restaurant in temple city
sichuan corner no the one that uh anna
and jeremy took us to chengdu one is
hindu impression
i know
it's a balder chinese place it's like
chinese fine dining and i never saw that
before i think i know what you're
talking about but my friend that took me
there never told me the name because
they didn't want me to post about it um
so people won't come yeah they or they
come up to you with the ipad yeah i'm
like what the [ __ ]
during coven why are you so mad because
you're supposed to write [ __ ] down and
get your [ __ ] all [ __ ] up and then and
then when you go i didn't order this
they go yeah see that's the story she's
trying to change
that's what i'm used to you just
mentioned that like during like you just
got to feed people in person for the
first time right so like during covet i
assume you had to do a lot of takeout
and stuff like that well i i didn't cook
for people before this
i went straight from so from culinary
school i went to stage at restaurants so
i worked like behind the scenes on the
line and [ __ ] so and i hated it so then
i took it to social media and then now i
realize i can take social media to real
life what about when you're home alone
like covet all that stuff what's your
go-to ramen
yeah like
something quick something easy
do you like spicy ramen you have to make
a rum just like out of nowhere like like
the best you could think of best one
the kenja's ramen there for [ __ ] sake
anthony three straight in feed posts of
kendrick on him
straight
i saw what he was about to do to you i
got you
it's every episode really it's a thank
you though i honestly one person here a
decent heart shim wrong dude she said
it's all over here right
it's your [ __ ] go-to girl
is that your favorite though because you
love spicy [ __ ] love now shane did
everything
for this guy i like the black one
whatever that one is where it's like so
spicy okay but wait mama noodles are the
best all the shrimp one yeah the tom yum
oh those are noodles
the one in like the foil packaging and
[ __ ]
and they're smaller because southeast
asians are smaller so that's why you
have to eat too that's true so you're
classically trained yes i went to
college i don't even know that yeah no
no you do so you know how to make all
kinds of [ __ ] like french [ __ ] barbecues
oh for sure that's what they like teach
you in school like there's different
days for different cuisines um so so you
know a little bit of everything a little
bit did you ever have a donut day um
for baking and pastry um no donuts but
we did make bread and i got a really
good grade for bread that's cool
if you weren't in vietnamese cuisine
what would you feel like you might be
doing oh that's a good question french
french really that's very close to music
i know similar huh but
yeah a lot of techniques and flavors are
pretty similar
how did you put the fish sauce on the
ice cream
she said she didn't put the fish i know
but this is a little chewy brittle but
like how did you create that concrete
who who thought putting pepper on ice
cream was gonna be a good idea so ice
cream
sounds weirder than what i'm trying to
ask yeah so ice cream and chili oil has
like been around like i think earlier
this year in january the mcdonald's in
china had a special of chili oil and ice
cream
yeah so it's good it's really good so
try it but we took that and then we um
it was actually a mango sticky rice ice
cream oh my god that's good that sounds
good that sounds so good i couldn't even
taste it in my mouth and then you put
fish sauce on it not yet and then the
the fly by jing chili crisp on it and
then i made a fish sauce peanut brittle
oh
yeah there's an ice cream shop in
pasadena that has [ __ ] mango sticky
rice
oh the water but it's half the
wanderluck yes that's that's the ice
cream that we use they sponsored oh cool
one of this is good dude that's cool
thank you [ __ ] what are you thinking
about fish sauce
i've actually had the idea in mind for a
while now whoa and it's great let's rub
your alley steve that [ __ ] looks like
i'm trying to dip a dumpling into that
chili oil it's like if you guys had uh
tamarind vodka smirnoff tamarind vodka
wait i've never even heard of that oh
it's [ __ ] good
and it's it's got this it's got the
spice profile you know what i'm saying
and it tastes like it
[ __ ] good i love when he rolls it all
together i know dude have you
experimented with other styles outside
of like french and vietnamese because
was was your cooking school like cordon
bleu like french style or no it was um
the arts institute it was a scam
honestly i think culinary school is a
scam what makes it how would you make it
better
um
less money well what makes it a scam
first of all i never felt like i got my
money's worth of anything and um a lot
of times like towards the end of it they
were putting me in classes that i
already took without telling me that wow
and just only changing the name like
they were trying to be slick with the
same teacher so i was in the same
textbook and everything like today's
nuggets day we're doing all novice we're
doing dino nuggets and today's mcnugget
day did you feel like your other like
students were feeling the same way too
yeah oh for sure you probably could have
taken a master class for cheaper that's
what i'm saying like now we have so much
like so many other things that we can
take from like youtube masterclass um
all these other tools that you don't
need to go to culinary for culinary you
know what you need to do is you need an
apprentice under a master that would
halfway like verbally abuse you you
can't cook spit at you while he's
talking
that's that's who you need to learn
under spit in the food no no well
they're smoking a cigarette and while
they're talking to you they're spit all
over your face and then
you know see that's why i didn't like
working at restaurants it was very toxic
people yelling all the time yeah but in
that space you need to have like a a
proper culinary like you know dude the
kitchen is a different world man there's
some
yeah but gordon ramsay he'll yell at you
but you'll learn how to cook in like
five days five days on sale that's
extreme but i've been in like a couple
of hand like restaurants there the
environment is like pretty [ __ ] up
like everyone's just yelling everyone's
like angry and you get you don't get
paid that much like at all little to
nothing but is there a reason is there a
benefit to the yelling and the fast it's
no it's it's anxious it's anxiety very
entertaining it's it's high anxiety it's
a great reality so everyone's just
pissed like once you have all like you
have 10 people waiting for their orders
and each of the orders are the different
things all the time so it's like you
have to get all that [ __ ] out the
customers yelling at the waiter the
waiters yelling at the cooks the cooks
yelling at the line in the dishwasher
and everyone's yelling at each other
yeah everyone's just yelling yeah it's
[ __ ] wrong
but like but then when it's i don't know
about like your restaurant but most of
the restaurants i've been to like when
it's done though the rush is over
everyone forgets oh for sure and then we
have a family family meal after yeah
everyone just eats together yeah yeah
like if anybody's thinking of going to
culinary school i would advise you to
like just work in the kitchen first like
that's the best experience that you ever
get
would you tell women to mostly just go
work in the kitchen
stupid
yes
today's video is brought to you by
draftkings
the killer crossovers
they're nothing but net
jumpers the tenacious throwdown
ladies and gentlemen basketball is back
basketball draftkings the leader in
fantasy sports is celebrating the return
to the hardwood by giving new customers
a free shot of millions in total prizes
playing daily fantasy hoops is easy just
pick your lineup of pro basketball
players stay under the salary cap and
rack up points with three pointers
rebounds assists and more score big and
you can score big cash and with the free
shot at a million dollars in total
prizes there's no better time to show
off your basketball iq draftkings is
safe reliable and secure
but best of all you could withdraw and
deposit your cash whenever you want so
make sure you download the draftkings
app now and use the promo code off the
record for a shot at a million dollars
in total prizes that's the promo code
off the record after you download the
draftkings app there's a minimum five
dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details thank you draftkings
that's exactly what i'm saying i love
the restaurant environment though
because when it's on
okay i really love watercolors
yeah so i don't know i never was in the
kitchen i was a waiter you prefer being
in the kitchen with women i prefer
working in the kitchen with women i
think it's a lot of like male ego that i
i couldn't like get over
it was it was a lot men don't belong in
the kitchen no
who do you think
you see
i heard steve makes really good
sandwiches
what's your what's your ideal sandwich
what kind of bread you take his mom
makes for him puts in a brown bag gives
it to him
sarah lee dang you are delicious
white bread or sourdough i like
sourdough okay
okay you put a piece of oil you put
strip mustard on it you put bologna on
it you close the sandwich you know what
you don't toast it
he makes it into a spiral i do my
initials i do s
i had a buddy who grew up in louisiana
both him and his brother are 300 pounds
like muscly because they're just big
they're fat and uh
his mom at the beginning of the week
would take a piece of white bread
a hot dog ketchup and mustard roll it
put it into a saran wrap and the entire
fridge would be filled with it and they
called it redneck power bars because him
and his brother are so [ __ ] big they
would just come in after school and
destroy like 30 each so you're a cook
is that a hot dog or a sandwich
yeah hot dog
rolled into a white bread that's a
taquito it's called the power yeah
she would get like um a piece of uh like
wonder bread yeah get a hot dog roll it
roll it up
yeah and then and then wrap and then so
there's like 50 of them ready to go
no no i never heard that my ass could
probably only eat like two i did used to
just go home sometimes from school and i
would just open a pack of hot dogs and
eat it right out of the [ __ ] package
just wrong we're white trash people yeah
i know i know you didn't have chopsticks
in your house no but did you ever have
a stovetop cat camping because i would
do that after school i would stab my
[ __ ] chopstick into the hot dog and i
would just roast that [ __ ] all right oh
i've done that i've done that yeah
that's mom what did you use if you
didn't have chopsticks a pen before
wow that is the white thing to do yeah
but the metal could burn your head dumb
[ __ ] maybe it's not a medal a plastic
fork and then melt it there it is do you
flip it upside down so you're holding
the spike side to be honest i didn't
really do that very much although we did
eventually get like one of those ranges
in the kitchen where it had like a grill
and then i would cook hot dogs on that
but but i would just eat it raw out of
the package oh i got a question already
right is that what it is yeah with
something it's cured
when you were growing up did your
parents or your mom or whatever whoever
cooked in the house did they
force you to help or did they tell you
get the [ __ ] out of the kitchen
i that's why i went to culinary school i
didn't know how to cook oh wow mom's
like cooking space like that's all her
so that's when when i first started to
make videos we would fight a lot because
i was in her kitchen in hers that's like
her workshop yeah and she's like you're
making up men as well so we never get
along when we're in the kitchen together
so did you record those videos of you
guys fighting don't be hilarious no no
because that'd be funny if y'all cooking
and she comes in what the [ __ ] and then
you get into an argument that's
literally how it goes down is your mom a
cook she is oh she didn't give you
anything no no knowledge at all not
really like because they don't measure
anything so it's like you just smell it
you feel it and it's like i can't learn
from that but um yeah she gave you the
gift of good taste there you go because
if she could cook i learned
is through her cooking and her seasoning
that's why i'm so gr like gravitated
towards vietnamese food what's the
bombest thing that your mom made that
you love to eat
what is that it's a braised pork belly
yeah it's very like traditional is it
like a like egg yeah with eggs oh that
one oh
there's a sauce it's brown
it's like stewed right yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's braised yeah oh i know that
doesn't really like eat it over rice
homegrown meal i love how you spelled it
he spelled it t-o-t-k-a
do you spell tatter taste
there you go here i go c-h-i-t
pull it up jamie
i'm dead that's enough jamie yeah
it's always very quick little jamie
moments there you go so that's oh it's
like fat bacon
it's really delicious it's really
delicious yeah is there egg in there too
there is so for my recipe i think it's a
chinese version i use quail eggs yeah
there's a lot of chinese influences in
vietnamese food as well
um vietnamese food is like chinese and
french had a baby yeah with the
indigenous ingredients and a lot more
plants a lot of plants that's what i
like about it because it's like got so
many fresh so green veggies southeast
feel like thai or cambodia or some [ __ ]
coconut that's a lot of that tropical
fruits yeah yeah
delicious venezuelans i know these looks
like chinese food
there you go that's what it is the pork
belly is under it dude my elementary
school cafeterias are vietnamese food
oh [ __ ] am i too yeah holy [ __ ] yeah i
can't slide in the pulling dynamite yeah
that's hilarious so that's titka oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yo that stuff is good vegan
yes pork belly it's thick bacon yeah
it's [ __ ] bomb it's not cured so yeah
it's not real bacon and then the rice
soaks up the juices
so there's like a few different versions
of it do they serve that like a clay pot
yes oh okay i think i've had that
authentic and traditional god yeah
how does the clay pot affect the flavor
versus like a metal potter it's got lead
in the paint yeah wow that makes it
tasty yeah it's conductive 100 percent
do you do you know the real answer um
is there a really no
there is a real answer it's it's it's
for an easy um what is it like
even cooking yeah i see like the
temperature yeah
and it cooks all throughout so back to
your mom real quick does she have a
restaurant no she doesn't
but like she's not that good
[Applause]
she [ __ ] sucks bro yo
she she learned how to cook because she
got married and over in vietnam when you
get married you basically have to cook
for your you have to move in with your
husband's family and cook for for them
so that's how she like got into cooking
so who passes it down like your dad's
mom
no like it was just she had to learn
from like just
eating her mom's food
or
like just learning from neighbors stuff
like that
so that's how she learns sounds about
right i know
no youtube this looks good no youtube
vietnamese that [ __ ] is so nasty it's
gross that sucks that [ __ ] is so natural
it's not even fun i'm disrespecting
annie chuns man yeah what the hell i
found this in the vietnamese section at
walmart hey this is [ __ ]
ani chun's versus [ __ ] kenji bang
look it's got two and a half stars
actually it has two and a half stars you
guys actually tried it as nasty
oh you tried it he's gonna replace them
at walmart oh for sure i've tried a [ __ ]
ton of random things and like all the uh
instant pho is like gross what's the
best one there's actually one i still
have to try and it's uh it's in costco
actually um
i like the one that's like it's green
and you peel it like that like a cup of
noodle and you put water inside i like
that one
for fun like it's built into the bowl
yeah it's built into the bowl and then
the noodle that might be a costco is
that
i don't think so i went to 99 ranch or
something
i think it's kind of hard to make like
goods because you gotta have hours
phenomenal
right it's also the noodles the rice
noodles hard to keep didn't it
you know that's what it is something is
at costco it's like green and purple or
green
phenomenal phenomenal really good it's
phenomenal dude yeah
but it's at walmart you just said you
don't get this gonna want there you go
damn they got four one
two dollars
how many is in that how many is in that
memories in there
it's phenomenal there's 70 of them
70 a six count
76 76
air fried never dried right never grill
there you go right there
never fried this is just we don't know
what it is
it rhymes
phenomenal it's phenomenal
that just to spite somebody do it
despite steve dude make him your
motivation
i'm gonna make [ __ ] hot dog
sandwiches
please don't you're gonna appropriate
his culture please don't please actually
don't do that cheese dude
[ __ ] kid just come out with bologna
sandwiches with a splash of mustard
corn dogs if kenja's did
macaroni and cheese with hot dog slices
in it i'd [ __ ] punch you in the mouth
the velveeta was macaroni and cheese
[Music]
you